الان من عمان ينضم الينا اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
سياده اللواء كيف تبدو لك خارطه المواجهات
يعني لا يزال الموقف ضبابي بسبب شح
المعلومات الموثقه وتضارب
البيانات التي تقدم من طرفي الصراع يعني
لا يمكن الجزم بمعظم ما قيل من طرفي
الصراع باستثناء بعض الحالات المحدده
عندما اعلن السيطره على سلاح المهندسين
وجاء النفي القاطع عندما اعلن السيطره على
مطار مروي وجاء معلومات مؤكده الى درجه
يمكن للاعتماد عليها بانه تم استعادته
السيطره عليه ما عدا ذلك الجميع يدور في
حلقه مفرغه بسبب تضارب الاراء يعني ما بين
وقت واخر تم السيطره على معسكر في في الري
المصري تم السيطره على معسكر في منطقه
ولكن لا يوجد اي نوع من التوثيق الذي على
المتابع والمحلل يعتمد هذا هذا البيان على
انه معلومه حقيقيه يبني عليها ليضع قراءه
استشرافيه لمالات الامور في هذا السبب
نعود الى المقارنه بين القدرات العسكريه
للجانبين وتميزت قوات الدعم السريع او
الاسلحه التي لديها هي العربات المتنقله
القادره على الانتشار السريع ولكن قيل ان
الفريق البرهان كان قد اعلن عن
عن قوه تدخل تعتمر بامرته لديها هذه
القدرات
ايضا وبالتالي كيف
تجد انه يمكن
المقارنه بين الجانبين في هذا الاطار
يعني عندما نتحدث الرد السريع نتحدث عن
100 الف نعم هي ليست قوات حقيقيه
بالبنيه التنظيميه العسكريه هي القوات شبه
عسكري عندما نتحدث عن الاعلان
الفريق البرهان عن قوه التدخل السريع هو
تحدث عن ثلاث الاف ثلاثه الاف هذه على
غرار قوات التدخل السريع هي قوات تعتبر
ذات اهليه وكفاءه قتاليه عاليه تسمى
التدخل السريع في مكان تسمى العمليات
الخاصه في مكان اخر تسمى القوات الخاصه
تسمى كتائب بمكافحه الارهاب اذا هي دعنا
نقول قوات النخبه تكلف بمهام محدده لكن
الاعلان عنها كان قبل عده ايام فقط وتعتمر
بامره القائد العام
ويوظفها اذا دعني اقول هذا الرقم متواضع
اذا وضعت قوات التدخل السريع
الاعلان عنها قبل ايام واعتبر هذا الرساله
للدعم السريع ولكن يبدو انها كانت متواجده
من قبل الاعلان انما هذا كان تاكيدا على
وجودها ربما وكما قلت في الرساله بالدعم
السريع
يا سيدي هو الاعلان عنها كان قبل عده ايام
فقط وكانت رساله موجهه الى الفريق حميدتي
على ان هناك قوات نخبه معينه يمكن تنظيفها
لكن ستبقى بناء على الاعداد المطلوبه
وبناء على الجغرافيه الاحداث عندما نتحدث
عن السودان الحالي لنتحدث عن مليون و800
الف كيلو متر مربع نتحدث عن ثالث دوله في
العالم العربي بعد السعوديه والجزائر
نتحدث عن مسافات شاسعه جدا ما بين مروي
والخرطوم 350 كم اذا الان كيف يوظفها
اعتقد التوظيف المثالي لها سيكون في داخل
الخرطوم لماذا لان امكانيه توظيف تحتاج
الى وسائل ايصال على سبيل المثال رساله
الى كردفان او الى دارفور تحتاج الى وسائل
نقل سريعه تؤمنها في اللحظه المناسبه كما
يقال سبيس ان تايل وبالتالي تحتاج الى
طائرات نقل هل هذه موجوده او الموجوده اذا
هي رساله كانت اكثر منها يوجد قوات دعم
ويوجد قوات تدخل سريع لكن في ميزان القوه
ميزان القوه يميل حتما من حيث على القدرات
القتاليه والامداد اللوجستي لصالح القوات
الجيش السوداني لماذا يمتلك الطائرات
يمتلك الدبابات يمتلك حوالي 400 مدفع
مجرور 30 مدفع ذاتي يمتلك 73 طائره عموديه
من 43 طائره مقاتله يمتلك حوالي 80 طائره
ما بين طائره قتال وطائره هجوم ارضي يمتلك
دبابات اذا دعني اقول لديه مخزون من انواع
مختلفه من الاسلحه الخفيفه المتوسطه
الثقيله الارضيه الجويه بينما في الجانب
الاخر يوجد مئه الف مقاتل موزعين على
العديد من الولايات في السودان جميع
اسلحتها هي اليات في في الغالب اليات دفع
رباعي مزوده برشاشات متوسطه هو ثقيله
لكنها تتميز واؤكد تتميز بخفه الحركه
تتميز بامكانيه
تحقيق عامل السرعه والمفاجاه
الهجوم الصاعق العنيف والارتداد السريع
والاختباع اذا هنا هنا جيش منظم هنا قوات
شبه نظاميه تتميز
بالخفه والسرعه وقابليه الحركه وهذا يجعل
المقاربات مختلفه جيش منظم درس الخطط
العسكريه
ودرس في كليات حربيه قادته
الضباط والجنرالات درسوا كيف يحاربون في
الكليات الحربيه في حيين قوات الدعم
السريع تركيبتها مختلفه تماما واعتقد كانت
هذه احدى النقط الحساسه اصلا بين الجانبين
وبالتالي هذه النقطه ايضا كيف يمكن
المقارنه فيها
ومن لديه يعني الكفه الارجح بسبب هذه
الجزئيه بالتحديد هل بالضروره انه الجيش
ام ليس بالضروره
يا سيدي الان عندما نتحدث عن قوات
الرد السريع نتحدث كما قلت لك عن تنظيم
مختلف رغم انه تم اعدادها وتدريبها
وتاهيلها من قبل الضباط في الجيش السوداني
وهناك كان
منتدبين موجودين من ضباط الجيش السوداني
داخل قوات ارض السريع ولكن طبيعه المهام
تعتمد على التنظيم وبالتالي قلت لك ان
معظمها تعتمد سيارات الدفع الرباعي نعم
لديها اسلحه ثقيله لديه مدفعيه اذا طبيعه
المهام لماذا لان انطلاقها اصلا انطلاقها
اصلا لم يكن من بني عسكريه حقيقيه هي اصلا
كانت عباره عن الجنجويد وتم اعاده شهرها
وتوظيفها وربطها بالمخابرات بالمخابرات
الجويه في عام 2013 اذا دعني اقول من لحظه
انشائها مهامها مختلفه وبالتالي تن فسيكون
مختلف واذا اردت العمليه للمعارك مختلفه
مشكله الجيش السوداني في مواجهتها هو هنا
تشكيلات رئيسيه لا تتمتع بالمرونه ولا
بقابليه الحركه العاليه مقابل جماعات
صغيره تتميز بالمرونه وقابليه الحركه
وامكانيه الهجوم السريع الخاطف والارتداد
السريع شكرا جزيلا لك من عمان اللواء
فايزه الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي